jared
i mean i'm stalking you at this point
you know that's okay i don't mind look
at the gloves who are we wearing uh
you can take a guess
let's say it together one two three
gucci okay that's right right all season
long and happy st patrick's day thank
you i'm supporting um okay look i wanted
to ask you you're such a fashionista but
love this show you're barefooting a lot
of this show what was that like for you
to be barefooted in like t-shirts well
i've been practicing my whole life ever
since i was a little kid so it wasn't
too difficult but walking down the
street barefoot if you've ever lived in
new york you know there's one thing you
don't want to do is walk down that
street barefoot uh so that that was i
think i got a little stunt pay that day
all right ann and you finally met cause
she said she hadn't met jared i think
you finally met at south by southwest
what was it like to finally meet her as
yourself
it was great i love her work and uh i
was just thrilled to have the
opportunity
to to be in this with her and
you know every day she just
delivered
absolute you know magic and just a
perfect partner she did say that one day
on set she got you to break because she
did the father-son and house of gucci oh
yeah yeah maybe i might have just ran
into the other room or something uh
it was great we had a lot of fun it was
a good time um we you know i we love how
much you commit to all these characters
i know you've said that they kind of
become like real people to you what is
the goodbye process then how do you say
goodbye and is that emotional to let go
almost like a breakup
i mean
look when you make a commitment in any
way
when you let go um
there can be a morning process
you know some of the things are physical
is the way you move the way you laugh
the way you talk the accent
it can become habit so i think it's
normal that there's a little grace
period you don't just all of a sudden
hey i forgot about the last six months
of my life
um
yeah so there's a little bit of time and
you know it's the secret that i have a
deep passion
uh working immersively i am passionate
about that
and you know sometimes that uh
it's got its challenges but uh in this
case i adored the project the work was
incredible it was so challenging there
was so much dialogue i was just buried
in
speech after speech after speech and it
was a i learned a lot a little bit into
the accent oh did i the speech after
speech yes did you miss it you missed
the accident you know i do i loved the
accent i had a great team of people that
i worked with a big team of israelis
that supported me and taught me and and
guided me through the process my last
question i don't know if you're aware
but on tick-tock there is a trend about
how you are not aging so can you drop
the skin care routine what are the
secrets
i mean if i told you that
you know we'd be in trouble
maybe one day i'll maybe i'll write a
book i'll write the book give me one tip
i'll write the book no no no no
that's a long conversation but can we do
father son house of gucci no no no
that's
that's gaga's uh you know i don't want
to sacrilegious
i can say boof
that's about it boof well we love you on
the show if we were to get any awards
recognition which i think it should how
would that feel it would be amazing i
mean look to be acknowledged for your
work
it's a beautiful thing i fought
very hard for these opportunities
for many many years and now to be asked
to come in and solve these challenging
problems
it's a dream so yeah that'd be a lot of
fun